partnerships are a great way to maximize
or initiate distribution of your app
partnerships can be mutually beneficial
for many companies and can be cost
effective when you're just starting out
when thinking about potential partners
you need to think about touch points
which are the methods you used to
connect with your customers so is it a
face-to-face meeting is it through
online ads or is it through a
partnership you'll need to figure out
the life side of your customer and when
they need to solve the problem you have
the solution for four abarkment our
customers will be looking for a solution
to their dog-sitting needs when they are
going to travel let's think about the
behavior of a person that goes on
vacation and where we might find an
opportunity to connect with them when
they need us most this person might book
his flight online maybe search for a
hotel or Airbnb in his destination and
perhaps also rent a car for example we
could consider partnering with the
travel agency to be their preferred
dog-sitting service when booking with a
travel agency you'll have add-on options
like renting a car booking hotel flights
getting travel insurance and now we'll
pitch them adding dog-sitting now we
need to consider why somebody else would
want to partner with us in this case we
would be great for a travel agency
because they're now able to offer a more
holistic booking experience and being
the one-stop shop for their customers
more than that these players are usually
basing their modern affiliate networks
so they get a fee for each click or a
conversion coming from their site to
ours for us it's great because they are
putting us in front of people who are
planning to travel and we will be paying
them only for a successful outcome
either leads with your clicks or
customers so conversions it's a mutually
beneficial relationship now take YouTube
for example when they were just starting
out they saw a partnership with myspace
to host their videos and look where
YouTube is now you're actually watching
a YouTube hosted video right now on that
note let's hear from Steve Chen a
YouTube co-founder